مرحبًا ، اسمي كريسي لي روجرز ، أنا
مصور ومخرج أفلام تحت الماء
أعيش في ناشفيل تينيسي وأنا
أصلاً من هاواي ،
أحب أن الماء له ذاكرة لأنه
يتذكر الماضي
أنه على قيد الحياة إنها قوة الحياة هذه التي
نحتاج إليها  البقاء على قيد الحياة يمنح الحياة
ولا أعتقد أنني سأنتهي من تجربته أبدًا ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو كان متعاونًا مع الماء
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن ما أفعله بشكل مختلف عن معظم
المصورين الفوتوغرافيين تحت الماء هو
أنني أصور من فوق الماء.
باستخدام انكسار الضوء حتى ينتقل الضوء
في الماء أبطأ مما يفعله في الهواء ،
لذا تحصل على هذا النوع من الانحناء وأنا
أستخدم ذلك لإنشاء هذه الصور
التي هي نوع من عالم آخر وليست من
هذا
الواقع وأشعر أنني  يمكن نوعًا من الرسم مع
هذه الصور الفوتوغرافية ،
إنه شيء طورته للتو
على مدار 15 عامًا ربما
يكون هناك الكثير من التجارب التي
لا يفترض أن تعمل
كما لو كنت تتخطى هذه
الحواجز
ومعظم الصور  إنهم غير
صالحين للاستخدام
على سبيل المثال في آخر لقطة لي ، أصبح الماء
غامضًا
جدًا وظننت أنني سأضطر إلى
إنهاء التصوير وقلت لا ، سأقوم فقط
بدفع هذا الأمر وسأستخدمه
و  ثم هذه الصور لها
شعور مختلف تمامًا بالنسبة لهم ، فهي
ناعمة جدًا فهي رسامية للغاية ،
لذا فإن الدفع من خلال ذلك
يخلق
الأمل والجمال في النهاية
وهذا نوع من ما تدور حوله العملية
برمتها وأنا أحب ذلك  لا أعرف بالضبط
ما الذي سيحدث ، كانت
رؤيتي لكُتّاب الضوء هي
صورة قوية جدًا كانت
تلك الأنواع الثلاثة
منكم تعرفون الملائكة نوعًا
ما يرتفعون وينهضون ، لذا فهم نوعًا ما
ينظرون إلى
الإنسانية إلى الرسالة التي ورائهم  لقد كان كل عملي
دائمًا هو
الحرية والأمل
والمثابرة من خلال نقاط الضعف
وآمل أن يرى الآخرون
أنفسهم في الصور
ونقاط قوتهم